日本人の視聴者に聞きますあなたは
ジャンクフードがお好きですか
いや好きじゃないですよねなぜなら日本人
ほど味覚が優れている人種はありません
その事実は次のような人気動画が
証明しています初日本
初めての和食に大感激日本食が美味しすぎ
て思わず涙日本に来て
良かった
念願のお寿司感動で日本に引っ越す日本人
は
ジャンクフードが好きなわけがありません
しかし僕からするとこういう動画こそが
一部の日本人が
ジャンクフード
依存症になっていることを
証明しているように思います皆さんの声が
聞こえます動画に出ている人たち実際に
感動してるじゃんそうですよね多くの方は
実際に感動してますよね僕も初めてお寿司
を食べた時は本当に感動しましたアメリカ
に住んだことはあるからわかるアメリカ
より日本の方が食文化が大きく進んでる
いや全く同感ですアメリカ人として認め
たくないんですけど
普段から高志望公園分高糖質の食べ物を
食べているアメリカ人よりご飯味噌汁
おかず
漬物を食べている日本人の方が本当に味覚
が優れていると思います上下日本の良さを
世界に広めて何が悪い問題はここですこれ
らの動画は日本の良さを世界に広めてい
ないのです動画に出ている外国人は
初めて日本文化を
経験しているかもしれませんしかしそれは
1人か2人多くて数人でありそして
おそらくカメラが回っていなくてもそこで
食べていた
観光客ですじゃあなぜその食べている
ところをわざわざ収録しますかこれらの
動画は誰向けに作られていますか日本人
です動画のタイトルサムネイルそして
コメント欄を見ればそれは一目瞭然です
そしてこのような動画には3つの刺激的な
調味料が
必ず入っています
油
塩そして砂糖です日本の何々が凄すぎるが
油です日本人の優しさに救われましたが塩
になっています日本に来て良かったが
砂糖の役割を果たしていますそしてその
調味料を使った様々なレシピがあります
念願の和食に大号泣と日本の治安はマジで
神カフェイン入りの半日
教育を受けた自分は日本人が
羨ましいそしてより高糖質の自分の国は
もう限界だ日本に帰りたい
海外を知らない日本人にとってこれは
いくら食べてももっと食べたくなる食事
ですそしてそれはそうです人間は
褒められたいのです僕も自分の動画の
コメント強くチェックしますこの表現が
面白かったですとか
初めて見たこんなに日本語ができる外国人
とかさすが道元チャンネル登録して
良かったいやーこれは美味しいですね自分
も
永遠に食べてられますもっと言ってくれと
なります残念ながらそうこういう料理には
栄養素がほぼ入っていません道元そこは
撤去じゃなくて
撤回です
やだめっちゃ苦いうまく説明できないけど
道元って
ラーキオンかなんか不自然だやめて
酸っぱすぎるアクセントを教えている道元
が公開のアクセント間違えるなんて
ダメだ飲み込めないそうなんです
成長に必要なビタミンと食物繊維が入って
いるほど
まずいのですだから目の前に
チーズバーガーと
納豆玄米が
置かれていると僕も含めてみんなは
チーズバーガーと手が伸びてしまいます
ここで申し上げたいのはそれに気づいて今
日本人向けに
チーズバーガーかアメリカンドッグそして
クリームドーナツを大量に作っている企業
が
劇的に増えているっていうことです日本の
ことをひたすら褒めまくる外国人
YouTuber国内YouTuber
ニュース番組さえも
毎日のように増えていますここで日本人の
視聴者に聞きたいのはこれですマックと
バーガーキングはあなたの健康を考えて
メニューを決めていると思いますかそれと
も
企業の売上を考えていると思いますかそう
なんです
だからえげつない量の
マーガリンとトランス脂肪を食べ物に
ぶち込んでいるわけです日本の良さを世界
に広めているそれどころか自分の利益を
少しでも上げるためにどんどんと日本人に
安っぽい食材を食わせていますいかに日本
を安く大げさに褒められるか
必死に競争しています
最近その
競争が激しすぎて
ごく普通の道案内をまるで超感動的な
出来事かのように言う人間が何人かもい
ます
もうジャンル化していますじゃあ何同言
日本は悪い国バッシングした方がいいとで
も言いたいのか違います僕も日本が大好き
ですもう10年以上日本に住んでいますし
妻も日本人ですし自分の子供たちも日本の
パスポートしか持っていませんそして
アメリカに帰る予定がないため最近日本で
家を建てましたわかりますか
そうなんです日本が大好きだからこそこの
動画を作っています大好きな友達が知らず
に毎日安っぽい食材を食べているのを見
たくないからですそして知っていながらも
つい食べてしまう友達に外国人として言い
たいからです皆さん食生活を少し変えませ
んかこの高脂肪高糖質で
プライド高めのアメリカンダイエットを
辞めて
素晴らしき日本を作った
慎ましさと
謙虚さがあってバランスのとれた和食に
戻しませんかスイーツを食べるなとは言い
ません
僕が言いたいのは
毎日のクリスピークリームより
週1回の
抹茶大福の方が
美味しく食べられて自分のためそして
みんなのためにもなるんじゃないかなと
いうことです
いただきます